James thanks for joining us on short
notice we appreciate that well thanks
for having me I'm glad you guys didn't
lose my phone number no no even though
you went up big-time now doing CBS games
look at you we love it alright as a wide
receiver what did you see on the hit -
Odell Beckham jr. I just saw a guy
trying to make a tackle you know a
couple of weeks ago we were in LA and
can at the Hall of Fame and if you go
into the Hall of Fame and you look at
the highlight reels of the defensive
backs most of these guys would be broke
we're trying to play that it is so tough
being a defensive back because he knows
he can't hit him in the head and neck
area so he's trying to aim a little bit
low its foot does slip a little bit on
the turf and so maybe he goes a little
lower than what I expected but it I mean
it's a clean legal hit should it be
illegal if you're going low like what
even if you know he did not be intent no
no okay
you know and sometimes you see it a
little more on big players we saw it on
Rob Gronkowski a couple years ago where
he's so big
where were you supposed to hit him you
you can't I mean we've done it with the
quarterback in the pocket but I'm not
sure if you can do it with the wide
receiver we've made him a defenseless
wide receiver at times but you know the
ball was clearly in his hands you've got
to make the hit and so not that many
guys are going that low how often does
that happen
quarterbacks don't string the guys out
that often and and if you do change the
rules then you're going to open it up
for the offensive coordinators and by
that I mean they're going to find more
ways to throw balls to guys that are in
defensive positions that make defenders
hesitate but why were players so upset
on Twitter last night these are players
who understand the game not us you know
we're fans I saw some of the angst about
oh it's a preseason game well what if it
were week one what would that really
make it any different what if it were
one of these inner squad scrimmages that
you have where you're practicing against
another team and the guy does the same
thing any slips this is this is part of
the game
you know we saw one of our Superstars
and we saw the nervousness in his in his
actions afterwards you know trying to
get up trying to continue to move going
to the locker room almost by yourself
not even assistant with a trainer so he
was nervous about what had happened and
it's funny when you hurt when you hurt
your ankle like that it almost feels
like everything in your leg is burning
from the knee all the way down you don't
know what's hurt if I said you could you
could tell players you can have your
choice get hit in the head or get hit
below the knees or hit in that area
what would players take players who have
not been concussed would say hit in the
head players who have been concussed a
couple times and say bring it on low you
know you really don't win you know it
used to be you know that you exposing
somebody's ribs and you would hear that
I mean it you know you're driving to the
basket and in basketball you want a hard
foul you want a soft foul and what if
what are you supposed to do you have all
your crowd to plate a little bit what's
the hardest you ever got hit I got
flipped a couple of times where you kind
of land on your head and shoulders and
neck stuff like that and but the time
when I escaped the hardest hit I'm
running a crossing route in Milwaukee
Packers used to play half their games
there and ronnie Lott is playing
labeling and the ball is thrown just a
little bit high thrown about 12 feet 9
inches and I could only go up to about
12 feet 6 inches to get a ball in my
uniform and the ball just goes right
over my fingertips and Ronnie grabs me
and come down pretty easily and you know
I considered him a friend even though
he's a competitor and he said next time
I'm gonna have to hit you and we still
laugh about that to this day because he
could have unloaded on me at the time
how scary was he when you're going
across them
like you knew when he was there you can
admit it now how scary was running oh oh
yeah and you know I'm one whose tongue
in cheek about my courage you know I
want because I went across the deep
middle that's where I kind of
earn my living those 20 yards square ins
yeah that was that was a big router man
and to me it was a route where you you
prove your mettle you took the big hit
whether it was from Doug Planck whether
it was from Kenny easily whether it's
from Ronnie Lott you you survived those
hits and you got up you bounced up as
quickly as you could because you want to
show him that you were tough enough to
come across that area he's a Hall of
Famer James Lofton working for CBS
covering the NFL this year if I gave you
the Patriots or the field this year to
win it all who you take it you know I
might gamble and take the field
the Patriots you know it's funny as you
look around the league a lot of good
defensive units are littered with some
of their players that they've let go let
me let you add one more team the
Patriots and any other team versus the
field so now I'll take a team from the
NFC and kind of kind of cover myself so
do I have to name that team yeah well
now you're making it tough on me I see
who did I play for in the NFC oh the
Green Bay Packers what do you really
believe that you always believe in the
green and gold once you donít know God
well then you would have taken the
Raiders too since you've done the silver
in black you know we're not taking
Buffalo this year that's for sure hey
this is a bandwagon year for me because
I can jump on a lot of banned way I you
know the Raiders worried me because of
defense that secondaries not good James
yeah they what they win five games in
the last minute last year mm-hmm so
that's there's going to be a reset with
them I think I think there'll be though
they'll come down a little bit you know
III think that's at AFC West is a ten
and six to eight Nate division the
bottom of it if the LA Rams can know our
journey you can get it together a little
more they could be a mate and the top of
it maybe ten and six okay give me your
sneaky team this year and then I'll let
you go back to bed Nicci team yeah well
you know I'm working the ASC with CBS
and that sneaky team hopefully is
Jacksonville I got them three times in
the first four guys I didn't say sneaky
whoops
but they're sneaky though they're sneaky
can you can you get rid of can you cut
Blake bortles can you [ __ ] them yeah you
can definitely afford to do it because
you can't afford to pay a 91 million if
you get two hangnail but you know we
keep talking about this injury year I
mean you really have to be injured
beyond repair to get the 19 point 1
million you know you just can't have a
hamstring injury and say well my hammies
height give me 19 point four million but
he's not going to be there next year
providing that he providing that he
doesn't get injured you know where he
would have surgery and be rehabbing no
yeah but that's the last thing they want
is him to get on the pail to get hurt so
what I was saying is that he played and
he pulled is hammy you know then you
can't say oh my hamstring is still
hurting next year mmm all right well
good luck with that ma'am and see how
good you really are you're going to try
to dress up the Jacksonville Jaguars the
toughest thing is when you're doing
radio you can kind of make it up now I'm
responsible for the pictures if that
something really happened on the field I
got to talk about that well good luck
with that and we'll check in with you
during the season maybe after you know
the first month of the season you can
tell us all about Jacksonville now since
I don't have this on television in you
and I are talking what are the Dan ATS
doing right now they taking a break
donuts is that what's going on
let me see paulie's got a golf glove on
Fritzi could be looking at something has
nothing to do with the show
McLovin is drinking his coffee and I'm
not sure what Seton is doing so I'll
baton they're just being themselves I
think they okay it's what they're doing
yeah that sounds like it yeah all right
have fun okay I will
hi thank you better sighing James Lofton
on the Fame wide receiver the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience